Research shows that study sessions are most effective in small, short chunks.
Instead of cramming in a ten-hour study session,...
...it's much more effective to spread it out...
...into 20, 30-minute sessions over a few weeks.
This is because your brain is better at encoding information into the synapses...
...in short, repeated sessions as opposed to one large one.
And this is why even learning different skills, whether it's swimming,...
...tennis or a singing lesson, often follows the same format.
Practice, practice, practice!
Not only do practice tests put your brains in the environment,...
...but even if you make mistakes, they help identify gaps in your knowledge.
Practice tests have also been shown to increase confidence,...
...thereby leading to better performance.